today on the matt walsh show two people
died during the kenosha riots last night
the breakdown of law and order continues
and this is what happens when the
government simply refuses to do its job
and protect its citizens like it's
supposed to do
also five headlines including the
media's hysterical reaction to
nick sandman's uh great speech at the
rnc convention plus
teachers claim they were traumatized by
an active shooter drill
and now require money to heal their
emotional wounds
funny how that works and in our daily
cancellation we're going to cancel the
esteemed race baiter jameel hill
uh all of that on the way lots to cover
but but we start here with with
unfortunately
the inevitable three people shot in
kenosha last night too fatally as the
violent insurrection not just a riot in
insurrection
went into its third night in the city uh
nationwide we're on the third month
of all of this many of the details are
still hazy there's plenty of uh
plenty of plenty of video out there i
can't play most of it here because it's
extremely graphic but
here's what we know according to reports
and this is crucial context
the ineffectual useless boob of a
governor
tony evers uh turned down help and
reinforcement from the trump
administration
to assist in quelling the chaos and the
violence the administration
offered it he said no instead evers sent
in a small national guard deployment of
250 it was not enough
not nearly enough the violence escalated
as it has been and armed men the media
is calling them militia quote unquote
appeared on the scene
to protect private property from rioters
it appears that
one of the people who came to protect
private property wound up shooting and
killing
two people there are two separate
incidents
with multiple videos circulating online
as i said i can't play them
but if you want to look them up you can
and you can see it in one video
an armed man can be seen running away
from rioters who are pursuing him
one of the pursuers was also armed
apparently
the man who was running trips falls and
as the riders including the armed rider
lunge at him he opens fire and hits at
least two of them
now it seems pretty clear-cut that that
particular shooting in that case
was probably in self-defense he was
trying he was trying to get out of the
situation he was being pursued
uh he opened fire right before he was
about to be descended upon and you know
potentially killed
in another incident which which happened
before this one involving i believe the
same person someone is shot in the head
at a car dealership
the videos uh that i've seen in that
case are far less vivid and conclusive
but in fact here's one clip i can show
because it's not very graphic but it
also isn't very clear
but anyway take a look and see what you
can discern from this
[Applause]
so it appears that again the guy with
the gun was running away he was being
pursued
something was thrown at him you can't
tell what it is for my vantage point it
seemed to be something that was on fire
maybe a molotov cocktail or something
along those lines
and then the shooting happened so again
a lot is still unknown
but here are a few things we do know
okay
first of all you will hear that
the armed citizens the militia are white
supremacists
there is simply no information to
support that claim right now and it's a
claim being made by people
who call anyone who disagrees with or
resists the rioters
white supremacist just to illustrate
that point that they'll call anyone
white supremacist i want to quickly show
you this video from the riots on monday
night watch this this poor man got his
his business caught on fire
i'm sorry sir i'm very sorry about that
man
yeah really hey i have nothing to do
with that i'm trying to stop this [ __ ]
here
dude i'm gonna help this guy i don't get
if i get beat up
[Music]
they just threw a bottle at this guy
hey
[Music]
okay so what that's a difficult video to
watch what we appear to have there is an
elderly business owner trying to stop
looters from burning and ransacking his
store
they beat him unconscious and leave his
building in flames
and how was this incident characterized
by the riot defenders
well a noted uh race hustling dirk bag
by the name of tariq nasheed
is just a really bad guy uh he he chimed
in about this incident and look at how
he framed it on twitter is what he said
freedom fighters in kenosha defended
themselves from a suspected white
supremacist who was trying to attack
black people with an extinguisher as if
this was the 1960s still notice how the
karen tried to scare the people with
retaliation talk
black people are already being targeted
okay
so the elderly man trying to stop
looters from burning down his business
is a suspected white supremacist
and the scumbags who beat him
unconscious and stole his stuff
are freedom fighters my point here again
is
simply that when you hear the term white
supremacist applied to
anyone these days you can't take it at
face value
and that's the first thing about the
shootings last night the second point
is that most of the video floating
around
um appears to show that the shootings
were self-defense
as i said one of the incidents is pretty
clear the other one not so much
but i haven't seen any video that
indicates that this was an act of
premeditated murder by a white
supremacist that's how it's being
characterized by
dishonest race-baiting snakes but i have
not seen any evidence of that
and they haven't presented any evidence
of it if such evidence is presented in
the future then i'll take it into
account and change my opinion
accordingly i actually
will change my opinion based on facts
unlike a lot of these
people who are defending the writers so
those are those are the less clear
parts in the more sort of tentative
parts based on what we know
um you know there doesn't appear to be
any support for the weight racist white
supremacist murder narrative
and there does seem to be plenty of
support for the self-defense narrative
but who knows
you know that can change we'll see now
let's get to the even clearer parts of
this though the things that we can say
without any equivocation
two things there number one people have
a
right to exercise the second amendment
while protecting private property you do
not have a right
to destroy private private property
if you do get shot while in the process
of trying to destroy someone else's
property
or harm them personally then that will
be your fault
we can say this as a general statement
many of the writers and insurrectionists
believe they have some kind of god-given
sacred divinely enshrined
right to quite literally do whatever
they want wherever they want
to whoever they want however they want
if a man stands with a gun to stop them
from burning down his store or someone
else's store or anything else
they feel like this is a personal and
direct attack against them
these are people who have been driven
mad by their own entitlement
that's the first number two all of this
is happening
because of a monumental failure of
government unlike anything we've seen in
this country in generations
elected leaders are refusing to do their
jobs
refusing to protect their citizens there
is a way to put an end to all of this
and restore order
it wouldn't even be that difficult easy
for me to say of course as i sit here
but the point is that
there is an established blueprint for
these situations
the blueprint has not failed it's just
been ignored
and the blueprint is this meet the
insurrectionist with overwhelming force
arrest
every single person who throws a brick
lights a fire breaks a window
prosecute them to the fullest extent of
the law put lengthy prison sentences on
them
send the message that anyone involved in
this chaos will be sacrificing
years of their lives these scrawny
privileged punks
they don't want to go to prison they
don't want to spend years behind bars
with bubba and the boys
right now they know they won't even if
they're arrested which most likely they
won't be
they'll probably have charges dropped or
get fined for a misdemeanor or something
in portland they're cycling rioters
through the system like a ferris wheel
you know arrest them let them go arrest
them let them go arrest them let them go
round and round make that ferris wheel a
one-way ticket
and show up and after you've you know
before you do that you have to show up
on the streets with aggressive
overpowering force the rioters
you know they're out there using
umbrellas as shields it's a game to them
but just to them to the people who lost
their livelihoods their businesses their
homes their lives
it's not a game so make the rioters
understand the seriousness of the
situation
make them the government has the power
to make
them it refuses to use it and our
society slips further into the clutches
of anarchy
because of it but this is all their
fault
and whatever you think about the armed
quote-unquote militia that's
now showing up to fill in the gap whose
fault is that
it's the fault of our elected leaders
who have refused to do their jobs
and what we've learned like so many
other things in life if you won't do
your job someone else is going to do it
for you and you might not like the way
they do it
don't want to see that happen then once
again
do your damned job let's go to five
headlines
[Music]
before we get to the headlines here you
know the rnc is uh we're talking about
the rc in just a second but it's off to
a pretty good start this week blowing
the dc dnc out of the water in almost
every way
especially when it comes to ratings in
fact reports of monday night's
c-span viewership are six times the
opening night of the dnc
um which is pretty uh pretty astounding
not very surprising though
given what i was forced to watch last
week i guess i'm not i'm not too
surprised to see it
daily wire is uh matching this
enthusiasm with an even better lineup of
all access live to watch the rnc with
you at dailywire.com
uh starting today at 8 15 eastern 5 15
pacific i will be live streaming the
entire night
of rnc speakers and watching with you
uh taking your questions and your
comments and
telling you authoritatively not just
what i think but also what you should
think
about this don't don't think for
yourself okay let me do the thinking for
you
that's remember i'm the theocratic
fascist dictator that's the way this is
supposed to work
uh and we'll be hosting more live watch
parties every day for the rest of the
week so don't miss out all access
members get to join uh all access live
sessions where
one of us hopes hosts hop on every night
to uh
chat with you both in live stream and in
the comments so go to dailywire.com
walsh right now to get 20 off all access
with coupon code access dailywire.com
walsh coupon code access 20 off go there
now
okay so number one uh
uh number one is day two of the rnc
convention last night as just mentioned
you won't be surprised to learn that my
favorite moment was a speech
uh not from a non not from a politician
because my theory that politicians never
give interesting speeches ever
has been in my opinion confirmed by both
conventions
but luckily there's been some
non-political speeches that i thought
were pretty good
nick sandman the uh the kid who was
slandered by cnn
and other media companies and sued them
and forced them to settle the lawsuits
he spoke for several minutes uh he had a
lot to say that was quite relevant and
important but
i'm going to play just a clip of him
giving his side of the story
describing from his perspective what
happened on that
fateful day in dc watch this
my name is nick sandman and i'm the
teenager who was defamed by the media
after an encounter with a group of
protesters on the steps of the lincoln
memorial last year
before i begin i'd like to thank
president trump for the opportunity to
share some of my story
and why it matters so much to this
november's election
in 2019 i attended the march for life in
washington dc
where i demonstrated in defense of the
unborn
later that day i bought a make america
great again hat
because our president donald trump has
distinguished himself as one of the most
pro-life presidents
in the history of our country and i
wanted to express my support for him too
looking back now how could i possibly
imagine
that the simple act of putting on that
red hat
would unleash hate from the left and
make myself the target of network
and cable news networks nationwide being
from kentucky
the birthplace of abraham lincoln my
classmates and i visited the lincoln
memorial
i found myself face to face with nathan
phillips
and other professional protesters
looking to turn me
into the latest poster child showing why
trump is bad
well the media portrayed me as an
aggressor with a relentless
smirk on my face in reality the video
confirms i was standing with my hands
behind my back
and an awkward smile on my face that had
two thoughts
one don't do anything that might further
agitate the man banging a drum in my
face
and two i was trying to follow a family
friend's advice
never to do anything to embarrass your
family your school
or your community before i knew what was
happening
it was over one of mr phillips fellow
agitators yelled out
we got him it's all right here on video
and we won grandpa so yeah and then he
goes on to talk about cancel culture
and how it's you know wielded by the
media and the left to destroy people
they don't like a very effective speech
all around i mean this is a guy
you want to talk about victims of the
cancel culture this is this is one of
the classic examples of it
a very as i said effective and and the
best part is the media
just absolutely hated it uh
this was playing on cnn which is great
they were just really mad
salty as the kids would say and so they
lashed out again just spewing vitriol
at this kid many examples i could show
but let's just go with this one joe
lockhart is a cnn contributor
and he is i think very jealous that nick
sandman gets paid more from cnn than he
does
so he tweeted this i'm watching tonight
because it's important but i don't have
to watch this snot-nosed
entitled kid from kentucky talking about
salmon a
snot-nosed entitled kid from kentucky is
what he calls him
right well joe you know better to be a
snot-nosed entitled
kid than a snot-nosed entitled old fart
like you i mean if you have to choose
between the two that i mean that's
really the time to be snot-nosed and
entitled
as a kid we we all were um but you know
you're
what in your 50s 60s now and and you
still are and the thing is
yes nick is entitled he actually is
some people are entitled to certain
things he actually is entitled
to not be slandered and libeled
right he's legally entitled to that and
so if he's coming off as entitled
that's because he has a certain
entitlement a real legal entitlement
that is protection from libel and
slander that was infringed
and that's why now cnn is entitled to
pay him
for that that's how it works uh okay
number two
big news here new evidence was filed in
the george floyd case
it's a document from the hennepin county
medical examiner
dr andrew baker and
let me read this document to you in full
here's what it says a short document
filed in court
it says on may 31 2020 at 7 30 pm
assistant hennepin county
attorney patrick lofton and i met with
dr andrew baker
on microsoft teams all three of us were
at different locations dr baker said
that he had
and recently received the final
toxicology results from
mr george floyd's samples which were
analyzed by nms
labs a b shared his screen and showed us
the results he said that there
that uh where it says hospital blood
those samples are from mr floyd's
hospital admissions and were not
acquired
as autopsy a b said that these samples
are better for determining actual blood
toxicity than samples taken at the
autopsy samples taken out autopsy it may
have undergone post-mortem distribution
uh whatever that means abu walked us
down the list of substances for which
nms labs tested those values he
highlighted were
4 a.n.p a precursor and
metabolite of fentanyl present in mr
floyd's blood
methamphetamine which he describes as
very near the low end and a stimulant
hard on the heart
uh fentanyl he said that's pretty high
this level of fentanyl can cause
pulmonary edema
mr floyd's lungs were two to three times
their normal weight at autopsy that's a
fatal level of fentanyl under normal
circumstances
and then nor fentanyl uh a metabolite of
fentanyl
mr floyd's urine was tested for four
things and are redundant um
abe said that if mr floyd had been found
dead in his home or anywhere else
and there were no other contributing
factors he would conclude
that it was an overdose death okay
so he had left a level of fentanyl
system that's
fatal under normal circumstances uh and
under normal circumstances he would have
been ruled
an overdose these seem like important
details
now you could say well this is not in
normal circumstances the arrest
the knee on the neck contributed to it
yes but it's hard to see how you sustain
a murder charge
when a person has potentially fatal
levels of a toxin in their body which
they themselves
willingly ingested so more details in
that case that are that are interesting
number three the indie star reports
eight elementary school teachers who
were shot with airsoft guns
execution style during an active shooter
training drill last year
are suing the sheriff's department that
conducted the training the controversial
trading drill conducted at meadowland
elementary school in northern indiana
last year became national news after
teachers
uh reported being left bruised bloodied
and traumatized
the lawsuit filed last week in indiana's
northern federal court
claims that four white county sheriff
white county sheriff's deputies should
subject to teachers
to verbal threats exploitism screaming
in addition to being struck with plastic
pellets fired from airsoft guns
the teachers displayed obvious signs of
anguish and physical pain
but were humiliated to find the law
enforcement officers joking and laughing
at them
the complaint says the terrifying and
inexplicable experience left to teachers
with lasting physical and emotional
injuries
let's see and then it goes on a first
grade teacher was diagnosed with ptsd
after this
uh it continues it says eight teachers
out of approximately 35 that were
present
have signed the lawsuit um
according to the complaint the teachers
were broken up into small groups and
told by sheriff's deputies to line up
facing a wall and kneel
once they were kneeling an officer shot
the teachers across the backs
why what was the point of this um they
were not told to tell the other teacher
they were told not to tell the other
teachers waiting in another room for
their turn
and later in the day teachers were also
subject to a series of drills
in which they were instructed at
different times to hide in classrooms to
try and barricade doors
and to throw tennis balls at the
officers during each drill officers shot
the teachers with airsoft guns according
to the complaint
then it goes on physical and emotional
injuries
according to the complaint the teachers
experienced several
severe well it says several emotional
distress i'm pretty sure it means to say
severe emotional distress okay all right
now a few points here not to laugh at
their emotional distress
uh which i am a little bit this whole
scene just seems
completely outlandish first of all to
say you have ptsd from being shot with a
pellet gun
is absurd i'm sorry i i've been shot
with a pellet gun in my day many times
and really doesn't hurt that much um
and you know as long as you don't take a
pellet to the eye or anything and that
that could cause problems
so all of this whining about emotional
distress is
obviously ridiculous and just a bit of
theater from teachers who are looking
for a payday
second you know and as aside from all
that i've never quite understood even if
there's
if there is real emotional distress how
do you
quantify that in in terms of money
how do you put a certain dollar amount
on emotional well i
i have 50 million dollars worth of
emotional distress i think 50 million
dollars
would heal this this these my emotional
problems
40 million won't do it you know 55
million i don't need no just right there
at 50 million that's what i need
i have i've looked within myself and
realized that 50 million is what will
heal me that's never quite made sense to
me but
second um these active shooter drills
are also
completely ridiculous it just seems like
a really macabre
adult version of cops and robbers
it's fantasy role play in the guise of
safety training is what it is
the whole thing is a waste of time and
resources um
the you know why do the teachers need to
act out
being executed like
what do you need practice for that um
and why do the cops need practice doing
it that's a little bit disturbing too
so the whole thing is just is always the
the chances that
a particular school will actually
be the victim of a mass school shooting
is is so
vanishingly small that you can't
possibly justify the amount of time and
energy and resources put into stuff like
this
even if you know these kinds of drills
were effective which i don't think they
are at all
but now that doesn't mean that schools
shouldn't have policies in place and
ways to protect themselves
i'm just saying that acting out these
role play games
like they're in boot camp you know
training to be
to invade some middle eastern country or
something is i think totally ludicrous
and besides you know you can give the
instructions and tell people what to do
without shooting them with airsoft guns
when you do a fire drill
you don't actually like burn people you
know you don't
when you do the fire drill do you light
candles and then chase
the kids down the hallway and like start
singing their elbows
while they're running no um all you have
to do is just tell them okay this is
what we do here's here in case this
thing
probably won't happen but if it does
this is what we do
okay thanks now i know we can go about
our day and besides the training goes
out the window anyway once the bullets
start flying
but most people who are not professional
you know professional law enforcement
professional in the military
whatever once the bullets fly they're
just going to panic anyway
and do whatever seems the most
appropriate in that situation so
even if the scenario you act out
actually happens your little staged
production probably won't do any good
and really when it comes down to it
if there's a shooter going around
executing people room by room
you you can either try to get out of the
building
or if you have a gun to protect
yourselves you can use that which i
which i think would be great
if schools were able to actually protect
themselves in that way but if you're in
the room
and you have no gun and
you haven't left and the shooter comes
in
and you know you're literally backed
into a corner and he's the only one
armed
um i i just don't know that there's any
real strategy you can have in place
that's going to prevent horrible things
from happening and certainly throwing
tennis balls at him
isn't going to do anything um okay let's
go to number four don lemon of cnn is
finally
finally speaking out against the rioting
only took him about three months
but finally he has he's finally realized
that it's a problem
it's just it's not a problem in the way
that you probably think it's a problem
listen to this
i do think that this what you said
what's happening in kenosha is a
rorschach test
for the entire country and i think this
is a blind spot
for democrats i think democrats are
ignoring this problem are hoping that it
will go away
and it's not going to go away and so
unless someone comes up with a solution
over the next
73 days or 70 so however many days
68 days 68 days so it's not gonna
the problem is not going to be fixed by
then but what they can do
and i think maybe joe biden may be
afraid to do it
i'm not sure maybe he won't maybe he is
he's got to address
it he's got to come out and talk about
it he's got to do a speech like barack
obama did about race
he's got to come out and tell people
that he is going to deal with the issue
of police reform in this country and
that what's happening now is happening
under donald trump's
watch on donald trump's watch and when
he
is the president kamala harris is the
vice president
then they will take care of this problem
but guess what
the rioting has to stop chris as you
know
and i know it's showing up in the
polling it's showing up in focus groups
it is the only thing it is the only
thing
right now that is sticking
and the democrats tonight stuck with
that right
and they also stuck with the theme that
you said
the coronavirus you got coronavirus
and you have kenosha okay but you see
the caveat there he's speaking out
because it hurts democrats in the polls
that's what he's worried about he's not
worried about
people's lives livelihood businesses
being destroyed he's worried about
the polls which doesn't surprise me of
course
but it's it is always interesting when
they say that stuff out loud
number five finally uh what we've all
been waiting for really hoping for aaron
rodgers has chimed in
um about the shooting of jacob blake and
you know the social and cultural issues
at play as well
and we can all we can all see the matter
i think more clearly
now that the quarterback of the green
bay packers has expounded on the issue
so we as i said we've all been waiting
for this and uh
really glad that he's here to pass his
wisdom along here's what he had to say
i think like you know like i said in the
video
and like we talked about in the video
that we put out there's a
systemic problem and
until the problem is fixed this is
going to be an all too common sighting
in this country it's obviously it's home
you know being not far from green bay um
i'm not going to you know comment
directly on the video until
more facts come out but you know
obviously it's
something where you as a as a
non-police officer i think a lot of us
natural question is when
is lethal force necessary
and again i think that goes to a
systematic
problem that needs to be addressed at
some point you know there's antiquated
laws
uh that you know are prejudicial against
people of color
in this state i think the governor and
his
and the folks you know at the capitol
need to take a hard look at some of
those
systems that are in place yeah that just
has that has
major major hostage video vibes going on
all of these videos of these athletes
uh like brett favre and you know others
speaking about this
they all have hostage video vibes but
nothing quite like this
you can just imagine masked men with
guns in the background
whispering lines to him say systemic
racism
systemic racism say it uh i mean rogers
is
he's just going through a list of buzz
words and phrases
that he probably picked up when he
scanned the blm website right before
going in for the press conference
and he's just sitting there like um you
know
the thing is um there's systemic
underlying patriarchal
cisgendered privilege privilege
privilege contributing to uh
inequity and racial
injustice by the way
he says that antiquated laws have
something to do with it he mentions
antiqua
that's another buzz phrase he picked up
the antiquated laws
those antiquated laws are antiquated
i uh uh aaron what does antiquated mean
again
well it just means it means they're
they're very anti just means they're
antiquated that's what it means but
what what does that have to do with the
jacob blake shooting what antiquated
laws are we talking about the laws
against sexual assault
that's why there was a warrant for his
arrest i just don't know what laws he's
talking about here that have anything to
do with it well
and he doesn't know either of course
he's just he's just
babbling and um hoping that it'll be
enough to keep the
mob from coming after him and we'll see
if it does all right let's go to our
daily cancellation
now for our daily cancellation we're
going to be shortened to the point here
i'm i'm
i'm late on this i admit and part of me
was hesitant to perform this
cancellation because it seems so
redundant i mean why bother canceling
jameel hill
she's already permanently canceled every
day is another cancelable offense from
her
but this one i just can't let go i can't
resist it's the principle of it
so here's the latest from jamil uh a
tweet it says
been reading isabelle wilkerson's new
book cast that's a book about racism in
america i haven't read it don't plan to
she says if you were of the opinion that
the united states wasn't nearly as bad
as nazi germany
how wrong you are can't encourage you
enough to read this masterpiece
if jamil hill calls a book a masterpiece
i'll be pretty sure to avoid it but
nearly as bad as nazi germany now
obviously the very fact that you can
even make this statement without being
carted off to a camp somewhere is proof
in and of itself that it's completely
false jamil hill's
entire career at this point is proof
that the statement is false her only
existed her existence is focused around
complaining about america and the
president and telling us how evil our
country is
and she does very well for herself she
makes plenty of money
very comfortable let me ask you how much
money do you think you could make
or could have made in nazi germany if
you went into the business of
criticizing germany and hitler
i mean how prominent and successful do
you think you could have been
some people did in fact do that it
wasn't much of a business
and uh and you know and they had to do
it while they were in hiding and most of
them wound up dead
so this cannot be emphasized enough the
first clue that you are not under a
fascist dictatorship
is that you can go out in public and say
we are under a fascist dictatorship
second clue is that actually in this
country you can do more than that you
can make that statement in the form of
burning a building
or throwing chunks of concrete at police
uh
and you'll probably emerge unscathed you
can go home after a fun night of violent
insurrection
pop some you know leftover chinese into
the microwave watch a little netflix
before bed
this should tell you something about the
level of fascism in america namely that
the level level is
zero unless we're counting you yourself
as
you know the violent bully wreaking
havoc and destruction
as the fascist in which case the level
of fascism in america is
you and you know we could go on for days
here giving other ways in which
modern america differs from nazi germany
because it differs in every conceivable
way
yet jamil hill is an allegedly educated
person saying this
and lots of allegedly educated people
agree
and have said similar so what does that
tell us
it tells us i think the familiar story
first that people in this country
are woefully ignorant of the basic facts
of history
we have reached catastrophic levels of
ignorance
now people in this country they know
some names hitler thomas jefferson
columbus
and of course they put all those people
on the same moral level and they know
some events you know world war
ii 911 the moon landing
the building of the pyramids you know
the pilgrims were in there somewhere in
between
but they have almost no fleshed out
understanding of any of these people or
events
and that's because a fleshed-out
in-depth understanding developing a real
grasp of a subject requires you to do
things like read full entire books
you want to know about the rise of nazi
nazism in
germany well read the rise and fall of
the third reich one of the great
nonfiction great history books of all
time in my view
but it's a thousand pages long and a
country full of people who have
melted their brains and destroyed their
capacity for concentration by ingesting
nothing but tv and movies and youtube
videos
aren't reading a thousand pages or even
10 pages
so this is a as i said crisis
catastrophic levels of ignorance that
we're dealing with in america
um and yet
you know p people we would say that we
have
we are maybe the most informed society
in the history of the world
we certainly have access to more
information than
any other society ever has in the modern
world
we have access to really all of the
accumulated
knowledge of mankind we have access to
in these little devices that we carry
around in our pockets
so we have access to a lot of
information we are
most of us very informed in the sense
that
we have a lot of disjointed bits of
trivia and little bits of this and that
bouncing around in our noggins um
but in terms of real understanding and
actual knowledge
of events and things that are occurring
around us and have occurred in history
we don't have very much of that at all
so that's the first thing second thing
is
of course just the immense
amount of privilege that you have to
have
that someone like jameel hill must have
she's a well-known prominent person i
don't know what her net worth is but
um i can pretty much guarantee you it's
considerably more than the average
person's net worth
and uh as i said she makes a living just
complaining about america and uh
in in in in often in quite absurd terms
very comfortable and yet she looks at
her
position in america and and what she
goes through
as equivalent to the persecution of
people under hitler and nazi germany
the little bit of discomfort that she
faces
you know in her mind it may as well be
getting shipped off to a concentration
camp
because she is so privileged
and it's the same story these writers
and looters
extremely extraordinarily privileged
people
who encounter a little bit of pushback a
few obstacles
a few things don't go that way in their
lives and they they cannot handle it to
them it is
it is a crisis it is a historic
persecution
it it it puts them you know in the same
category as
as as all of the horrifically oppressed
and persecuted people of history
so that is you want to talk about
privilege there it is right there
that's why jamil hill is of course
cancelled but you know as i said we
should be canceled again tomorrow and we
we could do this anytime
um and you know so every once in a while
we'll just we'll check in with what
jamil hill is doing and cancel her and
go about our business
so there it is uh that's it for today
make sure to tune in to the rnc
convention the watch party tonight again
all access
8 15 eastern time 5 15 pacific i'll talk
to you then
if not i'll see you tomorrow have a
great day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio was mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
20 20. hey everybody it's andrew clavin
host of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the american republic is
collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moon
has turned to blood but on the andrew
clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
[Music]
clayton